welcome to this video this is the
highlights video for round 10 of the
candidates tournament quickly going
through all the games to get a overview
what happened today you can also check
out the long videos of course for each
game separately to get into more detail
let's start with kayaking playing white
against and drinking kayaking with two
wins in the last two rounds certainly to
watch out for maybe starting a big
series of wins here let's see what
happens we caught as a so lien and it's
atamanov here with an early a six yeah
this a six move has some actually a move
that is good to fight the English attack
with Bishop III and Queen d2 s kayaking
off in place but it also allows some
other things and one of those is the
capture which kayaking played and now
Queen d3 this is a sight line that he
had played before so maybe I'd reckon
what actually anticipating that Queen c7
and Queen g3 this is the idea
getting the Queen to g3 and blacks Queen
c7 was actually I think it would be a
good reaction to get the Queen's trade
it and not allow the Queen to come up on
g3 just like that so we had the Queen
trade and we went to this end game
almost which had a white Singh advancing
the Jeep on this Jeep one is quite nice
it controls important squares but black
immediately fights for those squares and
what really does not have much better to
take to capture Queen takes and after a
five wide grab some space in the center
yeah I think this is pretty much a
position that is sort of hovering
between very slight edge for white and
end equality
and Dragan goes for a pretty logical
maneuver and he gets the LightSquared
Bishop off yeah this was traded and now
a five is one spot of the dried kinetic
as we witness later rock before here can
I can play Bishop b2 maybe a3 was an
interesting alternative yes this is not
helping
White is threatening Knight c3 and
Bishop e3 to trap the rook something
like that is a pretty funny rook trap so
after a three black actually needs to go
back and then you play Bishop d2 and
it's a bit comparable to the game
structure but there are still four looks
on the board which maybe gives right
more chances to play for an edge this
has played and now this rook basically
needed needs to get exchanged check yeah
castles and and now something curious
happened really because here check
you see check they repeated moves to
agree to a draw which I found a bit
surprising from my actions point of view
because what is 150 percent and if he
wants to do anything he needs to win a
game and well this position is probably
not like something super great for white
but he I guess has a very slight
advantage and why not press this you
don't risk anything and maybe you get
rewarded for being for being yeah just
being hard about that pushing as hard as
you can trying to grind out a win this
is the kind of position if you give that
to Carlson and he let him play that
against one of those two thousand seven
hundred cards you would win a couple of
games and lose none and you need to try
at least not quite sure why kayaking
didn't go for that I don't see a big
risk here and yeah well if it at the end
of there
and have a point missing you can ask
yourself why not play out such a game
okay
the next game to look at what am I going
to choose I go for chronic yes
yeah chronic lost terribly against kayak
in the wrong before is on 50% and
swindler is on -1 if I'm not mistaken
though they're both not in very good
shape let's see what happens
oh the dutch again bifida he had played
it earlier against mamedyarov so not
surprised to to chronic and i think a
wise decision and in any case to avoid
the goon fault again he lost so many
green cards again strongly gets its sick
so i should really do something else
yet you come Nick played the funny move
III you with germ is basically unknown
and must have come as a surprise well
not the kind of move that that that
unsettles you deeply as black it's not
very aggressive as you can witness it
does not look very aggressive yeah and
interestingly enough he now played the
moose after some long thought v6 which I
found very surprising why exactly be six
but ok I had expected g6 simply in the
vein of the the Leningrad Duchess he had
played against mamedyarov
maybe he was somewhat scared about I
don't know maybe I'm talking on sincere
but maybe he was scared about something
very direct happening here I don't
really think it is working but you never
know could be interesting and but the
normal looking move for causes e6 even a
stone ball is very much okay here after
e3 has been played yeah Wow b6 was
played and now Kramnik played quickly d5
which looks really strange but there is
an interesting idea and he takes control
over the central square on d5 and
basically forces black now to play c6 to
attack the center and this is very much
forced yeah yeah this type of position
um I guess should be okay for black but
it's still I guess within the territory
of being about equal yeah he played a
very quick d5 yeah which are not so sure
about maybe this could have been timed
better but we see after a couple of more
moves after a couple of more moves that
white retains the idea to play c4 and
after Bishop the former c3 and back he
indeed played C form yeah and here we
have one of those cases where one
drawback of the Dutch can can become
apparent one drawback of the Dutchess
yeah it's it's the move f5 the
characteristic move of the Dutch it
weakens the king side and it weakens the
pawn structure here and we see that
after a couple of more moves
it gets opened up and you can argue that
white has a slight advantage here
because of those weaknesses that are
easier for y to attack then let's say
the b3 weakness is relevant ever wide we
had a couple of more moves and here
sweeter plan is not to be six attacking
the rook in this position it's it seems
that the best move for white is 9 to d4
let's say Queen d7 and rooks e6 this is
probably good for a slight advantage for
white it's not a very very big advantage
and let's say I'm a position that a
computer would defend rather easily in
but for human it's not so easy to play
you're you're sort of noticed your
weaknesses and it's it's tricky to
defend 95 probably a move that black
should play here this would have been
rather logical continuation of the game
but ramnik played the moves look to
deform which certainly will
in many diagrams in in chess magazines
because now swindler could just shake on
h2 and win the exchange it's one of the
biggest blunders I recently witnessed in
top-level chess is just just blundered
the exchange basic name which really
shows that Kramnik is not in a good
shape I mean you could also already see
that in the rounds before but this is
sort of the icing on the cake it's
really just an exchange a new pond white
has only some active pieces left of
course to to set up some small threats
but some precise play is just giving
swinger the point he must find rook f6
blocking the diagonal and then tending
work g6 even with the counter-attack on
g2 and after that it's basically over
after a couple of more moves he have
kramnik resigned yeah he really just
blundered it away in one move which
pretty much ends his ambitions in this
tournament he's on minus one with that
her will have two points behind Arnaud
even if he wins this game tomorrow with
white against Russia it's a very very
vague hope to to get anywhere and yeah
the way is playing is not really
indicating that he should should win
against them against Arnold yes we go
with this witness back on 50% and in a
way in a way in the race again simply
because of the fact that he will play
are not in the last round and this is
probably the best possible round for to
play against him because you have a
pretty clear picture at this point if
just for argument's X wiggler wins the
game then you will catch up with a lot
and has this final game that might
decide the issue okay next game would be
around
de pollo serious got a Slav defense with
a six the Chobani ankle but quickly we
come to a very standard Slav position
with aronia playing a rather
conservative set up with III and Bishop
d3 the the the theory even recent theory
by a boys of rook says this is slightly
better for white but if we look at it in
the game just a couple of more moves
later it does not feel like much whiter
certainly looks a bit better with a
space but the power really quickly if
you look at this really quickly started
the play on the center with c5 attacking
White's pawn and it turned out that only
a couple of moves later he had a very
decent idea for how to play Knight over
to deform and it turned out that a
couple of moves later he really got
there after this slightly careless move
look to the 60 and this in the spot it
really came to this motif 94 with the
back rank now made being a big problem
yeah white needed to retreat and here a
couple of moves later we already see
that it's black who's got the more
active position with the D pawn however
black also has to be somewhat somewhat
cautious in a way as he's got many pawns
on dark squares b6 will follow and some
types of end games are tricky like
bishop and games so he really grabbed
space on the King side and now played
the move g5 which is probably giving
some of blacks initiative away as it
allows this regrouping at Topalov i
think ii said in the press conference
that he had underestimated this rookie -
bishop t - ؈ now we see that black has
the more active position you versus just
just very apparent with the cranium so
Aronian goes ahead with exchanging
queens it's a probably a wise decision
as here Blackstone needs to play one or
two precise moves but we saw later
exactly here it's the point where black
needs to be precise it's not rocket
science but still needs to be done but
you must play d3 you cannot allow King
to d3 and slow moves like that would
lend to black in trouble as white can
easily put more pressure on the d4 pawn
and it will fall at the end she played
d3 of course and this gave black enough
counter play by far yeah why had managed
to play this f4 can't around here they
repeated moves and agreed to a draw
there's simply nothing to play for I
think Aronian would have continued for a
very long time if possible but there's
simply nothing to do even it can easily
happen if you try to play for win that
you that you're going to do with so the
draw is pretty pretty em
understandable decision yeah not great
for Aronian in its wins badly and white
games are the games where they're
usually more achievable that was black
okay the final game to look at is Anand
Mahmud Yara our tournament leader former
world champion vision or not play
mamedyarov who just won against Iranian
a very important game and certainly with
the win would be really in the race so
let's see what Normandy era was doing it
was black night off and again we got h3
played the main line no gates at least
in this tournament
yeah my videographer is setting up his
pieces in a very normal way for the for
the scavenging and for the cameras tech
type of position was g4 yes played h6
sort of blocking g5 for the moment and
otherwise developed and after f4 he went
to 97 which is interesting it intense
this check and yeah white needs
to address that and I did that with the
chat with this idea to interpose with
the bishop and we know I got this
position where I can put this on the
chat we have like has canceled long
which is very uncommon in the in the
Sicilian and in the night off especially
well so he has may you cancel norm where
sometimes in the browser but it's um
it's really uncommon okay um it's a
position that is probably about equal
but still needs to be played played with
some some caution mostly by white these
two pieces are very good bishop on e6 is
nicely protected by the pawn the 1955 is
yeah just very obviously a good piece
and here's a healthy structure only d6
is a bit weak and the King is a bit weak
so white needs to address some points
and he did so with Bishop f1 the point
that he needed to address us the very
terrible piece on g2 always looking at
the pornea and he gets this regrouped
quickly see some tries at a repetition
by Anand and draw obviously suits him
King b8 like avoids that and now we see
the knight coming to d5 this is of
course a main resource for white the
knight on d5 is not in any way worse
than the knight on e5 for black and if
black should decide to take it's
actually an interesting question
depending on the concrete circumstance
how white recaptures rook takes make
sense to keep pressure here but this
improves the pawn structure a bit and
maybe allows some bishop bishop ideas it
didn't happen he didn't take couple of
moves later white has build up some
pressure on d6 and he also will see
three he has initiated
this idea Bishop over to be three or
possibly to a form and after ninety six
Quincy for Queen eighty-seven it is
moved to a team and here on my MIDI are
off a greet or offered draw and this was
accepted by Anand what understandably so
assets and maintains his lead and white
really does not have much to to play for
him but the same actually applies for
black it's very tricky to make any
progress as you if you look at let's say
the pawn structure black has no porn
break whatsoever and it's not so clear
what trades are good for him
trading on d5 is questionable and what
are you doing exactly as black to
improve your position you also have the
Queen on a somewhat strange spot on a
seven its I guess a very equal position
and that could have been played on but
the tournament tactics for honored
clearly indicates the draw is good and
Mahmud yarn off obviously didn't see a
way to continue without taking two big
risks which is the way is also quite
understandable he's got the problem that
he's also lost the first game against
honored and with the winner you could
also even the try break it's in this
position is not really easy to do
anything anything special okay what I'm
going to do now is quickly pull up the
the tournament table to discuss what can
happen in the last four Romans just give
me a second all right here we got
tournament cross table I'm using the
weekend chess for that one of the
premier chess news sites okay we see the
tournament area obviously are not
leading by one point ahead of aronia one
and a half points out of memory are of
kayaking in sweida
the interesting point is the remaining
games form for Anand he still faces
kayaking and sweedler and both of them
have played draws in the first round in
the first turn so if one of them
enos wiggler wins against Arnold they
would not only reduce the distance to
have a point but also would have the
better tie break swimmer place in the
last round against Ireland so what I was
already explaining after the chronic
swindler game is that let's say Sevilla
wins one of his next games yeah he does
not have any easy games of course but
let's say he wins one of them now let's
say he beats the power off just for
argument's sake he's playing sinned
against a parliament this can easily be
a big fight let's say spinner wins that
and if we she only plays draws and the
remaining games and that comes to the
final game in the final round it's
really a somehow manages to win with
Blackie he's got it so it's not like
it's decided already and the same
basically applies for Coyoacan he also
has a game left against Anand also with
Wyatt actually some he also has this
chance this is why I was a bit critical
why I didn't push anymore today because
he needs one more win to get this kind
of decisive game and yeah from a MIDI
Aravind aronia the problem is they both
have those zeros against V so they have
the worst I break even if huronian wins
two games and Rishi draws the rest he's
out simply because Anand had the better
has the better tiebreak remembered yar
off even can if he wins out of four
games he wins three draws one and Allen
draws all it's still enough for vision
so the most realistic scenario is of
course of course if I'm not losses games
everything's opening up again and this
is in fact for round for the next round
even very interesting as he will play
Kramnik with black was completely out of
shape but well he's still formidable
normally with white so you don't know
you don't know maybe you get some nice
preparation in normal view or gets his
kind of position way where you can put
some pressure on
okay let's hope for interesting chess
tomorrow I'll be covering it of course
until then bye